the man charged in the kidnapping of a
Chinese scholar allegedly spoke about
what makes an ideal victim a prosecutor
described the alleged comments at Brent
Christensen second court hearing
yesterday he's held without bond after
the June kidnapping of Chinese
researcher ying yang shang a crowd
gathered outside the courthouse
yesterday was signed supporting chang
who's still missing
Anna Warner is at the University of
Illinois with the disturbing revelations
and a good morning good morning so this
bus stop right behind me that is where
Jiang was standing under a tree when
Christensen allegedly picked her up in
his car now a criminal complaint talks
about how Christensen allegedly
discussed abducting Jiang now we're
learning there are more recordings taken
during the time the FBI was monitoring
Christensen before his arrest
prosecutors told the court Wednesday
that Brent Christensen was recorded
allegedly describing how yin yang jiang
fought and resisted during her abduction
but the US attorney also said that at a
vigil for Jiang attended by Christensen
that's him in black
he described the characteristics of an
ideal victim and may have even possibly
pointed out people he considered other
potential victims in the crowd former
FBI profiler Mary Ellen O'Toole says
suspects sometimes do show up at events
for victims it could have made him feel
very important he knows that he is the
person that's responsible for all of
this fear and another reason that he
could go to a vigil is to find out
what's going on in the investigation if
you go to the vigil and you leave the
vigil in his mind he's not arrested so
maybe he's not developed as a suspect
attorneys for Christensen addressed
reporters after the judge's decision
Wednesday to keep him in custody without
bond we weren't surprised at the outcome
of this hearings it's not unusual for
failed to be denied a criminal complaint
alleges Christiansen admitted to
investigators he gave an Asian woman a
ride the day of Jang's June 9th
disappearance but said he let her out of
his car last week investigators said
they don't believe the 26-year old
Chinese scholar is still alive
the announcement came as a blow to
Jiang's family who flew to the u.s. from
China after she disappeared
Jidong Wang is representing Jiang's
family how difficult is it for the
family to simply not know where she is
this do have the hope no one told them
it's 100% that no one told them we have
the body yet they still deeply in their
mind Union might be still alive
somewhere as he said the family's still
holding out hope even though police have
said clearly they do not believe Zhang
is still alive in fact the family plans
today to drive a couple of hours from
here to look for her in a place where
someone said they thought they might
have seen her meanwhile the attorney
says that if Christiansen is convicted
Gail the family has said very clearly to
the US attorney they want the death
penalty as a family remember you hold
that hope but the circumstances do not
sound good thank you very much Anna